what stories that you hear going viral
is real like i know you're debunking one
by one by one what are some of the
stories that we hear about each other
that is real this is real that is fake
yeah so there was one there was one on
your your uh your call sheet here that
had uh was about a girl um in nova
scotia or mom in nova scotia whose
mother or whose daughter was was being
groomed for human trafficking social
media halifax is that what you're
talking about that's one yeah cbc news
but you also like see that on tick tock
like every day every single day on tick
tock there's these mothers taking videos
of their like 14 year old daughters
doing like these dances and stuff like
that it's i mean dance moms it's insane
so
that that's the real so so think think
about it this way national center for
missing exploited children very very
reputable source incredible organization
um they found that in a five-year period
they had an 846
increase in suspected child trafficking
cases why and that's just children that
doesn't mean 20 year old college girls
or anything like that just children
it's the smartphone
right it's a broadband connected
microcomputer that allows you to order a
child to your hotel room
the same way you can order a pizza and
for about the same price
so
and and why
that that's always the question we've
got to ask is why did that happen well
the reason why is because for the first
time in history
a non-familial 40 year old man who's 2
000 miles away from a 12 year old girl
who just said she's mad at her dad which
is every 12 year old girl at some point
right at the very moment of
vulnerability that man can start
grooming that girl over a period or in
increasingly boys
over a period of of days to months to
sometimes years in order to bring her in
and then once once he's got her in and
it's a numbers game for him it's amazing
you're saying they're messaging the kids
hey i saw that you just posted something
you're mad i'm here for you buddy
whatever dad's trying to keep you from
growing up right he you know he just
wants you to be a little girl you're so
you're so pretty hey give me a photo hey
give me a better photo you give me a
better photo this is the part of the
story where chris hansen normally walks
around exactly that photo that photo
that you just that you just sent me yeah
i'm gonna actually post that on your on
your uh on your grade school facebook
page if you don't send me more photos
right and that's called sextortion
and then which is actually a form of
human trafficking and then it just gets
you know worse and worse and worse now i
need you to meet me and they know that
they've got to talk to 10 girls i mean
just make the math easy here right they
got to talk to 10 girls to get five to
communicate with them to get three to
agree to a meeting to get one to
actually show up and that one who shows
up it's a freaking sales funnel it's an
absolute sales funnel now look at it
this way too
and this is a this kind of brings it all
back to what we were talking about
before which is really the
commoditization of women
when i mean we speak on this issue all
over the world
and when we talk about uh
girls getting trafficked people are like
oh yeah man that's that's really sad and
that's really sad
we talk about boys getting trafficked
and people freaking are up in arms
they're like that's
absolutely not where are they we're
going to be pedo hunters we're going to
go after these guys absolutely it goes
the other way goes the other way so so
why so far-fetched why do people get so
angry
when they hear that boys are trafficked
but they just get sad when they hear
that girls are trafficked
right and that is a societal question
it's because we are groomed and we could
talk about media and all that
from a very young age to commoditize
women and girls
so when you hear about women and girls
being being sold
you expect it
when you hear about it happening with
boys very interesting very very
interesting right very interesting what
you now you know listen for me
this is a very uh uh
there's certain topics that my blood
boils obviously
did you see the last rambo did you guys
watch the last ramble yeah yeah the
whole thing with his niece when he goes
across the border or was it rambling
i thought it was rainbow did you talk
about yeah rambo it was rainbow yeah
yeah you didn't see the last round no no
it's not about human trafficking it cuts
the guys yeah
let me tell you it's a story about his
niece being human trafficked in in
mexico
and then
when you get when you have a family when
you have something happens when you have
taken another movie taken liam neeson i
can't watch those movies i watch liam
neeson i want to you know it's it's it
produces a certain kind of a certain set
of skills
certain set of skills and my skills if i
find you i will find you and i find you
you know that whole thing i'll kill you
yeah i will kill you but and then man on
fire becomes a
follow documentary
i had these guys watching one night when
we're putting them
together
yeah but it upsets you is what you're
saying it's it's very you've got
here's what's weird though here's what's
weird so
we can sit there and talk about
vaccine you'll have the conversation we
can sit there and talk about war
afghanistan conversation we can sit and
talk about a lot of different topics
and people will listen to it this is one
of those topics that's very
uncomfortable to listen to
so because it's uncomfortable to listen
to i wonder how much of media covers
this
because people don't want to hear this
don't want to listen to this don't want
to think yeah but there but it needs to
be talked about because it's happening
yeah because once you're in it
you're you you don't you don't know
you're on the web like we're going to
post your picture on the school
what's your response to that do you say
let me go talk to my mommy and daddy
mommy this guy just said he's going to
do this what do i do
do i talk to my friends do i work you're
in you're in a web what being said
yeah makes it uncomfortable you know is
what nick said earlier it's
you have to come to terms with
they're not the bad guy
i'm the guy going to the strip club i'm
the guy going to the bachelor party i am
enabling this and that's a very hard
thing you know it's like you look you
look into the darkness and then the
darkness looks back right so it's like
but the thing is nick man we're not
conditioned to view women as a commodity
like
the the woman is the the commodity on
earth
it brings life
it's it is the number one thing in the
world the female body
keeps our species going it is the most
precious thing on earth i mean there
have been wars
fought over women
there's women like everything that a man
has ever done on earth right the reason
that we sit in in that traffic the
reason that we work is to keep that
woman happy i live in a cardboard box if
i don't give a [ __ ] i want to live in a
nice place exactly everything that we do
you said something the other episode
you're like i want to know what that
chick
and the outrage of boys
and you know the shock factor and the
sadness with women let me let me post
something for you we hear a teacher male
teacher molest his 15 year old student
that's disgusting it's [ __ ] red
we hear the same female teacher has had
sex with a 15 year old boy what's up
homie yeah
what's up with that so uh i don't have
the educational background to dissect
this is a very animated question
but what what i can't say like if a 16
year old boy bangs his teacher you know
that all the homies are like what up bro
is this a personal question
something you want to get off your chest
yeah yeah
there was a teacher when i was 16. i
wish i had that story but let him
uh
no
so all these different questions that we
came down to like these aren't problems
i could solve you know what problem i
can solve and we're really good at
solving
is going after the human trafficker
because the common denominator in that
whole equation is a human trafficker
right you cannot have a human
trafficking victim if you do not have a
human trafficker that's why we focus all
of our time and tension and resources on
on going after that human trafficker
because i can't solve the
commoditization of women issue right
it's a it's a national conversation we
have to have and i'm gonna get tons of
heat for this but um you can also make
an argument that um that women in some
sense actually want to be commoditized
but by only only by the right person
right so so like i can't i can't solve
that problem you could have a great
comedy bit right there
i i can't i can't solve that problem but
what i can solve is going after that
human trafficker to make sure that when
that vulnerable girl says that she is
mad at her dad
there's nobody there to exploit that
moment
right so so again you know you look at
the businesses that you build it's all
about it's all about the problems you
can solve and not focusing on those and
not getting distracted by the ones that
you can't i can't solve the
i can't solve that stuff and even if
adrenochrome is
real let's say that you know people
really are drinking the blood of
children in their basement one we're
going to see it in the data eventually
and we don't see it two
you're going to see at least some
prosecutions because is there corruption
in law enforcement and in the judicial
system absolutely are they all corrupt
no
they're not and i think this whole
epstein case just just proves that so we
we
we're going to see it in the data
eventually we're going to see it in the
prosecutions
what we are
going to
uh what we what we need to focus on
primarily is what is actually happening
at scale within the business of human
trafficking and that's that human
trafficker exploiting a girl on social
media transferring her to another
platform and then getting her in that
stable and and the reason that that you
know i say we can reduce human
trafficking by 80 globally
um and why i think why i think we can
actually do that is because that 80
increase happened because of technology
so we take by taking that technology
focus and actually using that weapon
which makes it easier to catch enemies
way easier and and the the achilles heel
of human traffic that what is actually
happening in human trafficking is that
uh they have to advertise right price is
bottomed out yeah they got to do
business at scale right which means they
have to advertise at scale that's enough
anymore i mean now thanks to de blasio
they can just walk around the streets of
new york again man and you know like you
know door-to-door but one thing real
quick tom i mean you keep saying the
human trafficker you know
am i to understand that this is these
are one-offs i had always thought that
this was entire rings and that this was
a syndicate that this was gangs and no
it's it's a lot like terrorism these
days right terrorism is you know
within al-qaeda in in isis in these
these different groups it's uh it's a
top-down hierarchy but for the most part
it's just a loose affiliation of like
minds
right um and you have the same thing
within uh within the human trafficking
market i mean they will the these human
traffickers will coordinate um if you go
to uh
uh the instagram handle um at cara the
huntress um who's one of our senior
targeting analysts she actually breaks
she has a whole
youtube series called hunting with the
huntress and she usually breaks down
what these human traffickers are doing
um they they share best practices
they have conferences
where they get together and talk about
how they're going to do different things
and what's what's the best practice for
moving money and we've infiltrated their
groups and
they talk to us like they think they're
talking other traffickers i mean it's
it's uh it's actually a lot of fun for
us that's crazy that's like it's a
business it's a business they do it for
money it's not ideology so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you